well actually you guys have all done the
cranking videos really now
don't let me talk about that bloody
crane game bollocks yeah
how much how much did you waste chris
i think how much is it 500 dollars you
might just burn that for fun i'm more
fun to setting it on fire than wasting
my time trying to catch that [ __ ]
monkey this is a good uh transition into
what you think about crane games [ __ ]
awful hate it never again i don't i
cause i recently did it uh as well on
connor's channel and i i asked connor i
was like so how much stuff did chris win
he's like oh a bag of chips and i was
like what no i won at least
two bags did he have arms yeah he won
two bags of chips and he won uh a
knock-off kettle and the reason was i
didn't cheat like connor i didn't ask
this stuff i was sorry could i have some
help that's what you're supposed to do
boring i like to play by the rulebook
look what happened
i'm a man of honor i play by the rules i
don't need help they're not playing by
honor why should you yeah to be fair i
did win though and the woman i was like
can i get my crisps out and she had to
like remove it from the machine and she
went yeah sure and then just put it back
on the shelf
and i was standing like you taking me
for a mug what's going on give me my
crisps and like a supervisor had to come
over and be like sorry sorry here's a
winner
there was a big sign on the machine that
said if it gets stuck where chris got
stuck that you win the prize yeah and
then he put it back bastards
it was awful there was like nothing fun
about it
yeah it's it's it's fun up to like the
first prize you win and then you just
kind of feel like a monkey pressing
buttons afterwards i was trying to get a
monkey curious george or something
wasn't it yeah yeah curious probably we
just gave up on that like the machine
took my money as well so not only did my
prize get like put back on the shelf
even though i'd won it fairly i put in
like you know 100 dollars just went up
in smoke i had to get a woman over to
try and get the money out and while she
was doing that i was still trying to
catch [ __ ] curious george above her
she was like digging through the machine
like trying to get my money out like a
indiana jones excavation [ __ ] i hate
crane games
everyone that plays crane games
especially hate conor for making me do
it never ever again
ever
it was a good arcade though that send
one was my favorite one i think it's in
japan i know yeah did it have the best
prizes no i genuinely think the prizes
were
uh
maybe the tighter one has the best ones
yeah i won i won the ramen maker the
[ __ ] kettle and it's just a kettle
it's a rebranded it's a kettlebell
well you put boiling water in there you
just put your noodles in and they're
like ramen kettles so it's just a cup
just like a bowl of but it's got like a
budget
knockoff of the nissan cup noodles
i mean honestly the favorite prize that
i got was my [ __ ] uh home ramen like
thai ramen they had they had instagram
that was like my favorite oh [ __ ] it's
cool just seeing the variation of
different machines that they have the
one there's one that was like a balance
board and uh
yeah there was a balance board for a
crane game so you move around with your
feet yeah like choose where the credits
oh that's pretty cool that's awful isn't
it you can't control this all right you
just cheat and get on the floor and move
it i can't think of any cool one i guess
i bought i want like aloe hand cream for
200 hello
i used one of the small ones and i was
like i'm putting 200 yen i've got this
like aloe hand cream isn't there a
better way to spend five hundred dollars
yeah of course there is i'm not doing it
for a smart financial decision
because people like you seeing you fail
chris yeah too fair you you crying at
curious george for 20 minutes
i love seeing you guys i think my blood
pressure went up that day
at one point i was like i was like in a
machine like [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] i
looked around there's like a little kid
just watching me oh
no
that's so good because it was i was
probably my strongest performance as
well and i was absolutely murdering all
these machines yeah but that's the
dichotomy of chris just struggling for
his life to get a bag of crisps
at that point like you've done how many
crane game machines like you're a
natural boy
you'd say that but the one that i did
with joey was by far the most difficult
oh really oh the changing one was
[ __ ] so hard it was tough it was
tough
although i still got more than chris
would you would you say that there was
there is an actual technique to crane
games now that you've done it like i
figured i figured out a technique okay i
think
here's the thing i think
some machines the level of difficulty
isn't decided by the crane it's the size
of the item they put in yeah right there
are some things that like boxes like
some of the figure boxes right yeah
they're like just too big where they're
just no matter where you push them
they're gonna fall in yeah and once they
fall into like a and like it's just like
you're like it's like you can't get it
out yeah yeah and so it's kind of
there's something you've got to reset it
yeah otherwise it's not going to work
and that's what you're going to call the
staff and be like sumimasen help me yeah
just supposed to sort of gradually pick
it up and nudge it slowly towards the
end
again like some boxes are so
big and so are not good at moving that
they'll just naturally just fall into
that the moment you start moving them
and they just hope that you give up yeah
i remember in my episode like i asked
the staff lady i was like is there like
a technique of any kind with any of
these and she's like oh like people who
are really good at it just like figure
out the physics and like figure out the
thing cool i have to be a physicist to
figure this [ __ ] out amazing you can
maybe make a profit from it if you're
like yeah really good but it's not worth
it like why would you do it yeah i
remember when i asked for advice in my
video so he so the guy like on the crane
like he tells me oh you got to get in
this position which was like the
position you you do to like before it
flips over right so he easily gets into
the gets into gets it into that position
and then he's just like okay so what you
do after you get in this position then
he opens the box and he goes
takes his hands out and goes you just
flip it over and it goes in the hole and
i'm just like brilliant all i need to do
is [ __ ] just have a pair of keys and
push it over with my hands why didn't
you tell me before what an easy
technique
just i just get like ptsd just thinking
about it i i thought chris was like just
playing it up for the camera but he was
genuinely furious after the video he was
just angry there's something about
exchanging that amount of money and just
getting nothing yeah nothing in return
stuff you you did no you didn't get what
was what you got was worthless no no i
got i got maybe like at best 200 quid
worth of stuff that's why i only played
rhythm games when i got arcades because
you know you get the experience you paid
for
massive helicopter ac30 going over to
take connor away
finally back to wales
playing game yeah great game
drop him in the sea of wales the place i
just made up those videos come out way
more fun than they are to shoot that's
for sure it was really it was like what
a four hour shoot yeah yeah it's right
now it's just not fun it was it was for
the first like hour and a half i thought
i was like oh this might be a decent
video and then like the rest of the
video it's like you just run out of
energy like i'm just like what do i say
about this what what do i say pushing
the same button for like the thousands
well then the video is kind of really
fun they're really
nice and easy to watch
would you win ren or something with it
he remembered her name
one of my favorite clips of all time is
when he's getting confused about ram and
ram and then i explained to him that ram
is her sister so
white ram
ram is a system
like a like a beast like a shade
like a sheep like a male shoot like a
sheep or something do you see a ram and
you're like that's a beast do we have a
ram no we don't actually well you never
bought a ram no no no no no no
we don't have a ram
do you know any twins in real life no
because the only twins i know in real
life then
the names are hammy and sammy
i don't know any twins that have like
rhyming names yeah i don't know i don't
have any rhyming names what's the story
of rick and roberto as well i guess that
makes more sense
yeah so we know we know yes i know
stories what's what is rem ram about
what where's the name of the shark
ram i mean is it is
yeah they're two maids and they're
demons
and uh they're very uh enjoyable
characters why do you like it so much
it's a good show why is it good
i like the characters
what do they do that make you think yes
they're very caring for the mink
it's like a son getting in trouble by
his dad i feel like i'm asking
reasonable questions here like what's
the attraction
to watch the show because there's you
know there's a few scenes with this
specific character yeah ram is just very
endearing yeah more so than most
animated
very applicable not as happy as you
thought
yeah legally online legally online
always legal
um don't watch it let me know what you
think all right
people would pay good money to watch you
actually yeah yeah absolutely you need
you need to do like a show where you
like commentate overall just you
watching like non-satoshi con anime
would be hilarious actually just it's
not perfect blue i'm not here
i already watched you see it's like
low-hanging fruit i watched acura again
for the first time in years the other
day yeah that's a beautiful film yeah
how amazing
yeah
i was like feeling emotional watching it
i was like yes this is emotional
perfection this is like what everything
is yeah it's amazing
like the animation is [ __ ] incredible
and that's why i need to i'm thinking
sort of to become you know like like the
anime man i want to i want to get into
anime i mean it's pretty realistic right
now there's a gap in the market there's
a gap in the market right why don't you
watch anime anymore
but don't go into this
crash
we've been into this before it's like
you don't watch it as much now
yeah pretty much so i could be the new
anime man please
please
watch this yeah i'll crack open uh an
australian side of that christmas
open now all right chris brought some
australian three oaks he brought some
three oak cider
these are actually pretty good they're
better on top but seeing a good job
changing subject isn't he
they're all reincarnation stories a
[ __ ] flowchart figure out what's
going on